let's go next to Harry from Columbus
Ohio Harry welcome
yes I can
thanks for taking my call now you don't
think that Joe Biden will run for
president in 2024 is that correct that's
that's it's just my guess yeah I mean
it's not like a prediction I just don't
think he's going to run no
okay split it 50 50. you think it's more
likely he will not run then he will run
yeah if you just give me even odds right
I mean I'm just saying I take the he
doesn't run side
can you briefly explain the reasons why
you think that is I know that you've
said that Kamala Harris had to walk back
a statement where she said oh we're
going to run she had to you know kind of
walk it back Kamala sorry my bad
um yeah no that's not why
here's the night where what here's where
I get that okay I just zoom out a little
bit
um Joe Biden's almost 80 years old or is
he 80 even I don't remember anyway he's
he's close to 80 or 80. and I don't know
that he ever really intended to be
president for eight years from the
get-go Jen saki would say Joe Biden
intends to run which I know is not a
Smoking Gun in and of itself but it was
very very careful language the one time
someone went beyond that when Kamala
said he's running and I'm his running
mate within 24 hours she walked it back
so I I have to imagine there's some
meaning to walking it back and quite
frankly with the rec record low approval
dating all the way back to 1946 it's not
clear he'd win I just don't know that 80
year old Joe Biden with a 37 percent
approval is going to say what I want to
do right now is start another
presidential campaign two years from now
it's it's just you know different
reasonable people can disagree
yeah I agree and I think I'm not so
convinced that he's not going to run
just okay I don't think there's enough
evidence but I do see your point now I
just want to get into the more
substantive part of it is do you think
that is why do we know his approval is
at you know is lower since you said
since the 40s since you said but
presidential uh incumbency win rates are
I think 66 I think we've had 30
presidents run for re-election in 21.
yeah um so I just don't know if it's
wise to have somebody new and fresh I
mean I know it's good content uh for
yourself to talk about potential
candidates I'm just worried about what
will happen if we bring in a limousine
liberal like Gavin Newsom yep
um I'm I'm very scared of somebody who
is in Joe Biden frankly I think it's
potentially scary either way I mean when
I think about Biden versus Trump
uh Biden is the incumbent and Trump
hasn't even announced and those polls
are basically 50 50 already so if it's
Biden Trump again I'm not confident
Biden wins if it's DeSantis Biden I do
think DeSantis being higher energy and
younger will confer somewhat of an
advantage and I also don't think that
that looks particularly good for Biden
either so I get what you're saying the
power of incumbency is significant we
also may be in a new political era where
the where incumbency is less powerful I
mean Trump just lost and he was a
one-term president
so I don't know about that I think
you're making all valid points but I
think there's also another story to be
told
I agree thanks for going over all that I
appreciate it have a great day my
pleasure thank you I that's a that's a
powerful phone call uh very very strong